salut c'est heu reux aujourd'hui on va
parler du samsung galaxy note 9 qui va
arriver très bientôt
on ne reçoit pas très longtemps cette
semaine quelques jours n'a faut de sa
leçon que nous donne enfin la date de
présentation de ce samsung galaxy note 9
qui va être présentée le 9 août à
brooklyn à new york
dans cette vidéo on va faire un tour un
peu complet de toutes les filles de
toutes les rumeurs de toutes les
tendances qui se profile
autour de ces samsung galaxy note 9 on
va regarder à quoi pourrait ressembler
quelles sont les nouveautés et au final
est-ce que de ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
comme un faux est ce qu'il pourrait être
intéressant oui ou non ils sont vivants
[Musique]
ils seront présentés le 9 août prochain
à brooklyn ont alors fait tous notre
petit carton d'invitation pour suivre la
conférence sur internet
certains ont reçu carrément une petite
invitation officielle pour être présents
l'événement malheureusement c'est pas
mon cas j'y serai pas ne vous inquiétez
pas on va en parler donc on va le suivre
restez connectés et à vos idées vous
parce qu'aller voir énormément de choses
à dire sur la présentation de ce samsung
galaxy note 9
si vous vous souvenez bien le nôtre
c'est avait été un vrai fiasco il ya eu
un rappel des produits parce qu'elle est
une batterie explosive
le député d'asnières a quand même
relativement rassuré dans les modèles
haut de gamme cette année on a eu le s9
et s9 plus est a priori le note 9 serait
surtout une évolution du nom de suite en
se basant sur les s9 ps n'est plus son
nom de code smn 960 fc un petit nom
effectivement très sympathique
on le voit ce sens parce qu'il a reçu la
certification de la fcc c'est la
commission américaine des communications
qui attribue une autorisation de mise
sur le marché des smartphones aux états
unis de ce qui est fait en termes
d'image de la face avant de l'écran de
la protection de la face avant et du dos
on voit qu'on a un design est quand même
relativement inchangé par rapport au
galaxy note suite le changement pour
arriver l'année prochaine avec le no 10
et les aces 10 et 10 plus voir si la
dénomination changera ou pas on en
parlera très très prochainement en
attendant on va effectivement une
bordure sur le haut et sur le bas adam
kosh samsung s'est moqué d'apple et de
certains deux encoches eu pour l'instant
n'ont pas toujours succombé à l'encoche
est-ce que ça arrivera sur les disques
sas est possible on verra ça plus tard
toujours est il que sur ceux note 9
l'encoche ne sera pas au rendez vous
vous allez retrouver à l'avant un grand
écran oled a priori de 6,3 pouces à
l'arrière un double appareil photo juste
en dessous un capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour venir déverrouiller votre
appareil comme vous le dites zain qui
reste relativement inchangés on a vu que
le s9 est une évolution du et suit le
note 9 qu'aucune évolution du 28 alors
une évolution oui non pas si la grève y
avoir des nouveautés dans ce samsung
galaxy note 9 et notamment la nouveauté
la nouveauté principale va venir du fpn
c'est à dire que nous présente samsung
dans un petit teaser on voit le s pen on
voit un bouton suffit
enfin mettre un peu le cheval de
bataille de samsung sur ce produit cette
année un stand qui se connecterait en
bluetooth qui aurait un micro en haut
parleurs on imagine par extrapolation
une fonction dictaphone
pourquoi pas savoure avoir un sens ça
pour être pratique
on imagine effectivement espen toujours
plus précis toujours plus de points de
reconnaissance sur l'écran pour pouvoir
faire des dessins pour pouvoir faire des
créations toujours plus poussée alors on
n'est pas sûr de la tablette on est sûr
de la fable est sur un grand galaxy note
en tout cas le fait d'arracher de
toujours plus précis ça un vrai sens il
faut aussi avoir un sac un peu plus
performant de ce qu'on trouve sur le s9
s9 plus aux états unis devra avoir un
qualcomm c'est un dragon 845 en europe
autour a plutôt un processeur exynos
mais qu'il devrait être plus performant
qui s 9,9 plus on doit pouvoir en
trouver le modèle de base on s'y giga de
ram et 128 giga de stockage toujours
extensible et une version plus haut de
gamme 8 gigas de ram et 512 giga de
stockage une batterie entre 3800 50
millions paire eur et 4000 milliampères
heures une batterie qui est forcément un
peu plus lourde et qui ferait que cet
appareil serait un peu plus lourd que
son prédécesseur mais n'y aura cette
fois ci une plus grosse autonomie et on
l'espère pas du tout une batterie
explosive
cette fois ci pas de fiasco on efface
complètement les mauvais souvenirs qu'on
a sur le galaxy note 7% trouvé que le
galaxy note 9 avec une vraie bonne
autonomie
une autre nouveauté de la gamme note va
venir du module caméra du double module
caméra à l'arrière avec une ouverture
variable comme on peut retrouver dans
les esses 9,9 plus tu permettra de faire
des photos d'excellente qualité en
faible luminosité savait qu'en début
d'année samsung a frappé fort avec 6,9 s
9 plus avec cette lentille ouverture
variable
on a vu qu effectivement derrière huawei
a répliqué avec le pépin pro on a
vraiment eu deux photophone vraiment
excellent en ce début d'année
celui ci pourrait enfoncer le clou pour
le deuxième sommet de 2018 on va
attendre la réponse d'apple
un mois après et justement la date de
sortie de ce samsung galaxy note 9 pas
anodine elle se situe un mois avant
l'annoncé des nouveaux iphone des
nouveaux produits apple pour la rentrée
en septembre 2018 ça me saoule mais pas
forcément que peut un peu l'herbe sous
le pied à apple vendre sa gamme notes
pendant encore ds9 et s9 plus en faisant
parler lui ça pour éviter qu'on se ruent
chez apple
et pour continuer à gagner des parts de
marché autre nouveauté intéressante et
pas des moindres bic
version de bixby qui arriverait enfin en
français alléluia alléluia parce que
pour l'instant dicks billets toujours
pas en français si vous voulez
l'utiliser il faut parler la langue de
shakespeare langue de molière pour
l'instant c'est un petit peu mis de côté
aux oubliettes cette fois ci on aura une
bixby encore plus intelligent encore
plus autonome et qui cette fois ci
paraît votre langue
ça c'est plutôt un excellent de bons
points positifs on aurait toujours un
port jack du lfc de l'usb type c'est
pour de la recharge et du bluetooth 5.0
et tournerait sous android 8.110 en
termes de tarifs forcément ce n'est pas
un produit qui va être cadeau cadeaux il
a situé toujours au dessus des 1000
euros forcément produits très haut de
gamme oblige donc ça doit faire un
résumé une meilleure autonomie avec une
plus grosse batterie un nouveau espen
avec de nouvelles fonctionnalités
toujours plus puissants toujours plus
performants et une nouvelle caméra avec
une lentille ouverture variable volonté
puisque j'ai pu recueillir aujourd'hui
comme un fonds comme fuite comme
différentes rumeurs sur ce samsung
galaxy note 9
je vous invite bien évidemment à vous
abonner à rester connectés parce qu'on
va en reparler très très très
prochainement on est sur le qui vive
on en reparlera dès sa présentation
officielle pour un petit peu décrite
essaie de comprendre et de voir si ces
notes ne fait intéressant alors sur le
papier par rapport aux infos que j'ai
aujourd'hui on voit effectivement que 99
des produits qui situe entre le no 8 et
le s9 plus même s'il paraît pas
révolutionnaire sur le papier avec des
innovations forte majeur il semble
néanmoins quand même relativement
intéressant la question à se poser en
vacances et si vous avez de suite et que
ça vaut le coup de changer j'en suis
clairement pas du tout persuadé très
clairement consommateurs sur 10
si vous adorez ce 9 non plus si vous
avez ensuite non plus si vous avez un
produit antérieur et que vous voulez
utiliser un hespel ça peut avoir un sens
mais tout ça est évidemment on en
reparlera le 9 août prochain d'ici là
portez vous bien soyez sages
n'oubliez pas laisser des jolies pousse
nos questions suggestions directement en
bas en commentaire abonnez-vous qui à
très bientôt bastien
[Musique]